Japan's train system ranked by statista
is the most efficient in the world
the us though is far behind it's tied
for 11th best roughly 15 million people
ride the subway each day in Japan's
capital city around 11 million more
daily Riders than New York Subway we
compared the Tokyo and New York subways
to find out how Japan's rail system got
so far ahead of the United States
take a look at this map of New York City
subway system now compare that to
Tokyo's map
a key distinction where the public
transit connections intersect
in New York public transit commuters
into Manhattan likely only have these
options to disembark Japan's map has
more points of connection what's really
distinctive about Tokyo and actually
Japanese cities more generally is they
all interconnect commuter rails connect
directly with City subway tracks which
reduces congestion and unnecessary
transfers you just ride the train all
the way out to your final destination
you don't have to be paying attention to
your transfer station you just fall
asleep and you know when you're going to
wake up near your station these easy
commutes are key for the 2.4 million
people traveling into Tokyo daily from
outside the city on top of that tokyoids
only need one of two cards to pay for
most public transportation systems not
just in the city but also in many parts
of Japan and in New York you have to
often have a different card to get on
any of the ridership system it's not
like an integrated pay system or
governing system see you have to use all
these different tickets to ride the
public rail systems in some cases these
separate rail systems are the result of
different jurisdictions that oversee
Transit the subway for example is owned
by the city and leased to the
Metropolitan Transportation Authority
better known as the MTA which in turn is
controlled by the New York state
government and New Jersey Transit which
connects to New York City is run by the
New Jersey Department of Transportation
while New York doesn't have fully
integrated public transit connections
some aspects are improving first is
payment we now have the ability to pay
with a credit card when you go into a
Subway so you don't have to have a
special metro card which will be made
obsolete eventually I think the goal is
to eventually have one fee and one
system and that will pay you through all
of it
[Music]
2020 and 2021 during the kova 19
pandemic Tokyo Metro the largest subway
company in the city has been profitable
compare that to the MTA which
historically operates at a loss its
outstanding debt is forecast to hit 47
billion dollars by 2026. a key reason
for this difference central government
funding Japan heavily invests in public
transportation the national government
owns about 53 percent of Tokyo Metro and
the Metropolitan government of Tokyo
owns about 47 percent after the second
world war there was a continuous
investment in the public transit system
which is primarily the Subways the Jr
system and the private commuter rail
systems that all interconnect there's
never been a let up in continued
investment and adding lines and making
them work better the MTA on the other
hand is not owned by other private
companies its funding comes from
multiple places including taxes the city
and state governments and some federal
funding the MTA also makes money by
selling bonds it's one of the top
issuers of municipal bonds in the entire
U.S one of the largest buckets of
funding for both the New York and Tokyo
Subways comes directly from riders in
Japan's capital companies have
flexibility to charge more it's all fair
by distance so you you get your fare at
the end so depending on which system you
take the cost for Riders can be anywhere
from 170 to 430 Yen which converts to
about 1.27 to 3.22 the main New York
Subway fares are flat though the LIRR
and Metro North prices vary by zone
right now about 40 percent of the mta's
funding comes from the fare box from the
what the Riders pay to ride that number
has gone down a lot which is why we're
redoing the funding model because many
white-collar workers have worked from
home since 2020 there have been less
Riders and thus less Revenue this has
worsened the mta's financial situation
to help fill the funding Gap and account
for inflation prices will increase
slightly from 2.75 to around 2.86 later
this year
in Japan public transportation has a
reputation for being staunchly on time
in 2017 one commuter rail connecting
Tokyo to sakuba famously apologized for
having a train leave 20 seconds early
but the Tokyo Subways can face some
hiccups Tokyo Metro posts delays from
the past 35 days in April of this year
several train lines were running about
10 minutes late in New York City delays
are common in 2022 New York City
passengers waited an average of an
additional 64 minutes on platforms
cumulatively each month as well as an
extra 18 minutes on the train but the
MTA says that's an improvement we have
right now the best on-time performance
of our subway system in over 10 years it
may not be up to Asia's standards but
for New York it's really a great step in
the right direction we have an old
system so there are things that go wrong
mechanically you have a huge system of
switches and interlockings which require
a ton of Maintenance Japan man's history
of investment in public transportation
gives Tokyo the upper hand for its rail
system it would take years if not
Decades of very significant investment
in the New York Subway system for it to
match the levels of efficiency as the
Tokyo subway system because they've been
working hard on that for the last 60
years
foreign
[Music]